So in some sense there is a call to
action within people now you know,
in any sort of quest story,
like the Hobbit,
let's say,
or the Lord of the rings,
for that matter.
You know,
the story always starts with a call to
action,
right?
For some reason or another,
the little hobbit character,
which by the way is,
you know,
the hobbits live in this little
protected place and they're not very big
and they're not very smart and they
don't know about the wide world beyond
them,
where the great forces of good and evil
are at combat.
And one hobbit who's a little bit more
adventurous than the rest gets called to
act,
gets called upon to act.
And in the Harvard stories,
it's usually the wizard who manages it,
right?
So it's a magical figure of some sort,
becomes extraordinarily wise and
extraordinarily old who might as well be
gone for all intents and purposes,
who says,
you know,
it's time for you to go and become a
thief.
Will.
That's what happens in the Hobbit,
right?
Because very weird thing because
obviously that's Frodo,
right?
Photos,
the hobbit in,
in the Hobbit,
and Bilbo is the hobbit and the Lord of
the rings.
If I remembered the other way around.
Bilbo is the poverty and the hobbit.
Fine,
Bilbo.
Okay,
so bill will gets called to action and
he's gonna go.
He's gonna.
Go find a dragon while the dragon is the
same thing that swallowed Jonah.
It's the same story and the Jew and the
dragon has a treasure,
which is a weird thing.
It's like what's up with dragons,
right?
What do they hoard?
Virgins.
That's the St George Story.
It's a very,
very old story or goal and that's weird
behavior for a predatory lizard,
but anyways,
you accept that without any problem.
Of course in dragon lives underground in
a big mountain that was excavated by
doors and sits on a treasure.
It's like we go to.
We don't have any problem with that
idea.
Well,
why fate?
I mean really,
you really believe that announcer as
well?
Well enough to read the damn book and to
make the.
I mean,
how many people went and watched the
Lord of the Rings?
How many people?
And think about it worldwide.
How much money did a Harry Potter
generate?
You know,
I bet Harry Potter generated more money
than the remaining steel mills in
Britain.
If you calculated it across the amount
of time since those stories emerged.
Right?
So of course there's a lizard in a
predatory lizard and Harry Potter too.
It's the thing that skitters around
underneath hogwarts and turns you to
stone with the glance of it.
I owe.
And does that Lizard Hoard vergence?
Well,
what's the name of the woman that.
The girl that he kidnaps Jenny.
Right.
Okay.
What's the word?
Jenny from Virginia,
right.
Good.
She's Harry's first month interest and
he rescues her from the damn snake and
he gets parallels.
Won't paralyze,
wouldn't while he's doing it.
What rescue is Harry?
Phoenix?
Phoenix.
Okay.
So the six bites Harry.
And so he's going to die.
The Phoenix comes along.
Who owns the Phoenix?
Dumbledore.
Yeah.
What is the Phoenix do cries and cries
into Harry's wounds.
Yes,
but what happens then?
What happens to Harry?
He comes back to life to read his death
and Resurrection Story.
So the thing that's willing to die and
resurrect is the thing that gets the
virgin from the snake.
It's like,
does that make sense?
Well,
you think it makes sense even though you
don't really know why it makes sense.
And then what happens to the what adds
to the Phoenix after does that Burns
itself up into in a puff of flame and is
reborn.
So it's the story told twice.
The thing that dies in is reborn,
is the thing that conquers the
serpentine and rescues the feminine
roughly speaking.
So it's not gold in that situation,
but it doesn't matter.
It's the same story.
It's always the same story.
So,
and when you don't hear that story,
like when your culture is it providing
you with rich stories of that sort that
are derived directly from your
tradition.
Somebody like an unemployed welfare
mother in Britain has it popped up full
fledged into her brilliant imagination
and lays out seven books and makes
herself more money than the queen.
Right?
Right.
And that,
you know,
it's a cinderella story.
It's a bloody amazing story.
And then there's all those books and all
those kids learn to read because of the
books.
And then there's all those movies and
everybody goes and sees them and no one
notices that they don't know what the
hell they're doing while they're doing
it.
And it follows the same old story.